dès la réouverture ils ont réservé en
salle de lecture où le quota est de
quatre visiteurs maximum pour la
consultation de documents originaux aux
archives historiques de la rue dit lié
avec les chercheurs ou autres juristes
les généalogistes compte parmi les
principaux usages et jean pierre martin
président d'une association qui a déjà
numérisé 500 mille pages moi je prends
en photo tous les contrats de mariage
après je laisse jeux mais sans en ligne
pour que des adhérents puissent y avoir
accès aux dans toute la france même
jusqu'au canada beaucoup le pouzin là
bas je pense qu aux archives il doit y
avoir plus de 2 millions de da pts état
civil mais il ya 20 millions de da pts
notariés et qui nous permettent de
remonter jusqu'en 1400 3e 37 430 et 430
me gérard vallier lui est engagée dans
une recherche personnelle et je
recherche des contrats de mariage des
années vers midi vers 1670 et si oui
c'est la seule façon de remonter ma
généalogie parce qu'il n'y a nulle tac
de paroissiaux verser date danse à ces
mouvements de toucher des actes qui ont
été écrits par les notaires océan 1650
voyez c'est assez fade moi ça me touche
un petit peu quoique je fais la liaison
quoi pour toucher feuilleter examiné
archivistes et utilisateurs sont invités
à prendre leurs précautions
donc il réserve à al avance leur
demi-journée et ensuite leur leurs
documents avec les références des
documents pour qu'on puisse les
commander à l'avancé on les met ensuite
sur sur des chariots pour éviter en fait
la manipulation de documents et de
troupes passait les documents de les
dater main à la main et doivent
évidemment porter le masque et se laver
les mains régulièrement au savon pour ne
pas abîmer les documents aussi on évite
le gel hydroalcoolique
vous pouvez prendre déjà 1 à documents
que vous souhaitez consulter
et le passé à ma collègue et après aller
en salle de lecture pour le consulter
beaucoup aujourd'hui afin d'éviter des
déplacements les archives propose aussi
la recherche à distance dans ce registre
des étudiants germanique de l'université
d'orléans du xviie siècle
sandrine mona identifie le procurateur
pour un travail de master ce compris
orientale j'essaye de retrouver le nom
d'une personne habitant dans l'année
nous a questionné je vais trois photos
il savait déjà précisément ce que
cherchait pour mémoire mais pour
beaucoup d'utilisateurs les visites sur
place reste nécessaire
depuis le début des années 2000 6
millions de pages ont bien été numérisés
et mises en ligne
c'est seulement 2 % du fonds d'archivés
mis bout-à-bout 32 km de documents sont
conservés sur les deux sites orléanais